[Music]
hello I'm Dustin Kirkland product
manager at Google and your host at coop
GaN Copenhagen I'm joined here by cash
Sajjad 'is the CEO and founder of cloud
66 and he's gonna tell us a little bit
about his path to kubernetes sure thank
you
so we are a SAS company we deliver
development tools for software companies
and as a result of being a SAS company
we were hosted our applications for the
past four and a half years on AWS ec2
normal you know a set up of a cloud set
up and as part of our products we were
building kubernetes clusters for our
customers to deploy their applications
ultimately the rigidity of including and
introducing new infrastructure
components to our own infrastructure set
up that runs garsik success led us to
move over to running kubernetes
ourselves while we are we consider
ourselves experts at communities and we
built that for our customers we wanted
to decouple the risk and not have too
much of an inception if you will so we
moved to the best communities that we
could find outside of cloud 66 and that
was Google gke so the migration planning
for us took about three to four months -
and most of it was spent around risk
mitigation and data transfer planning
for our customers to have we have
customers about 120 countries so there's
no night time there's no downtime we had
to do that in a seamless way as possible
as much as possible and then the
migration itself took a day and so we
planned the whole thing and we did
though the entire thing in it so three
to three to four months planning a day
to do the migration yes
so our move to gke was smooth as a
result we cost cut our costs
infrastructure costs by about 60% but my
I think the best takeaway that we took
away from from moving to kubernetes and
GK in this instance was it added the
agility of our production and operations
team we want to
to be able to introduce new components
enjoy infrastructure like search
components and we didn't want to learn
yet maintenance of yet another product
or having to go and outsource that from
third party product the third-party
vendors all around making us more
dependent on a variety of different
components
now that 60% cost savings on the
infrastructure is that primarily savings
on the management layer there is a part
that's not very tangible and that's how
much time we spend less on managing
infrastructure which is on the another
P&L which I wouldn't know much about I
don't have that much visibility over
because it's kind of funny money in a
way but when it comes to spend we now
tend to spin up bigger boxes as in VMs
and packed them much more efficiently
before we had one component that would
take over the entire server but would be
utilized at 20% now we can move
workloads around and make it more more
flexible right okay so kubernetes has
helped cloud 66 tell me a little bit
about cloud 66 is business what do you
guys do with kubernetes so our SAS
product we have two products one is the
scaffolding and building kubernetes
clusters for our customers but our focus
is not doing that as building the
container side of the story we mostly
focus on workloads that you don't run
inside of the containers like database
backups replication firewall audit
management access to service that's
called classics is maestro and we
actually built a product out of our
experience of moving to kubernetes and
managing our deployments do kubernetes
which we call cloud 66 skycap or
container delivery pipeline we had to
make sure two things happen before we
can move to kubernetes one is the
technical engineering side of it which
you have one application you usually
break it apart into micro services and
then you wrap them into containers and
you write a bunch of configuration files
for communities to run that part is the
easy part as an engineering team we've
been a fairly capable of doing that the
part that we had to make sure that
happens is we do we have the toolset to
change the mentality of the team that
not only all the entire application goes
at at the same time some things are
dependent on other ones when the
deployment happens how do we know that
now that we have to version controls
essentially
one gate and one docker registry for
example we can trace and track things
down we can track and trace things down
in terms of the assets that are now
broken apart into hundreds of containers
on micro-services how can we take care
of security in secrets and also make
sure that our IP is not linked into
leaked into one of the layers of a
docker image all of that led into
actually building a product out of that
experience we are a product company when
we provided as a SAS or one firm to our
customers so we took that opportunity
and product product eyes or our
learnings now application development on
kubernetes takes a bit of a different
approach what what did you learn on that
aspect of your journey on your road to
kubernetes that's a very good question
um so I've in previous life of act I've
worked a Software Architect for larger
enterprises mostly investment banks and
I've what I've experienced this was very
very similar to the experience that I
had with martin fowler's way of doing
micro services and service-oriented
architecture if you will based on
contracts it doesn't necessarily have to
be broken up into multiple services but
we found that applying those principles
when it comes to contract based
development and and having a definitive
API internal API between services always
helps
regardless of whether that code base is
one code base or you break it about into
physical different code bases great so I
understand that we've got a bit of a
demo here all right let's see it okay so
we had as part of classic sky cab which
is a container delivery pipe and into
kubernetes I have an application that is
just one simple service and I wanted to
deploy that to GK so here is a here's
what we do we have a concept of a
formation and formation for us is a
deployment destination it's like
environments don't cut it anymore
because you might have five productions
and twelve stages just because you can
do that based on kubernetes namespace we
do that and here I'm adding the
different parts of the application based
on templates communities native
templates that we have in a gate
repository
idea for us was to not wrap the
kubernetes api into yet another API to
just control the access of our team to
communities you wanted developers to
have the full access and
experience the full benefits of
kubernetes when it comes to templates
but also for the ops teams and Ops
people to have have a say over how
things are deployed so here I'm setting
up a a namespace for my kubernetes
formation and here I'm doing a
deployment of a service so this is a
normal kubernetes deploy deployment
assets as you can see and the idea is
that my ops team will dictate if you
want to deploy or add a deployment to
your communities how should it look like
for example if you're running on gke you
might want to run on cloud sequel as
well and therefore unique cloud proxy
for as a sidecar for production but this
is not a concern for staging
therefore my ops cars can dictate that
I'm gonna add the port for my service
enter the command that starts it in a
normal communities or doc a friendly way
in this instance I'm running Redis
directly here as a as a container and
this is all backed by a git repository
so you can use just normal git flow as
opposed to using the UI web UI and the
last step for this is to create a
service that represents that deployment
again this is my Ops teams opinion how
the service should look like and this
comes from a git repository itself so
you can you can evolve this here because
I'm deploying to gke instead of a node
balance I'm using a load balancer so GK
will fire that up for me and I save the
changes and because we were running
Redis we are going to run Redis inside
of my cluster as well I'm going to just
fire up British now this could be a
helmet art that I can get off the shelf
and just deploy Redis or it could be my
team's opinion on how rare this should
be deployed in my organization and once
I have all those components what happens
is what we call taking a snapshot of
your application which will take a
snapshot of all your codebase all
pre-built images that you have for your
application
and then all of those will result in a
rendered set of communities native
configuration files that you can then
apply to your cluster I'm just going to
get the command that will generate that
we do support multi accounts so I'm just
going to switch it to our demo account
and then pipe that onto a coop control
and apply it to my cluster which is the
gke cluster that I have
so the namespace the secret which would
be the docker registry that we provide
all of that is going to get created the
namespace is there now let's check the
pods
great so the parts are running and I'm
gonna just streak quickly check the
service to make sure the load balancer
is up okay so the IP address is now
getting getting started I'm gonna just
put a watch on it hope it's up now okay
so I'm just gonna get the IP address
that GK gave me and there we are
so my app was is up and running but the
most importantly this was a simple app
obviously but it is based on the opinion
that my operations guys wants me to have
and I can then switch this formation
into another deployment target that is
running a home made communities class
that doesn't require certain things or
my optimized can can force my developers
to and every time you add a new
deployment for example they need to have
a sidecar from lock shipping for example
so it gives you the flexibility of a
kubernetes api without the risks of
being able to change things in the
entire cluster that you're not supposed
to a super interesting I can see how
this would drastically improve and speed
up some development cycles huh all right
cash thank you very much for your time
Cheers